this is
brent suter before the game i mean he's
been doing this for years he's got
miguel sanchez as a
part-time member of his band eric lauer
who has been sensational since the
all-star break yeah no kidding and he's
having a pretty good month of september
three starts at 2-0 record earned her an
average under one at point 93
three walks 17 punch-outs in those three
starts went down a great story here over
the last six weeks for the cubs
swings and misses at the high fastball
two quick outs for strikeout for eric
lauer yeah that's a big ass window has
been tearing up lefties this year chases
one out of the strike zone keegan
thompson didn't find out he was starting
until about 11 o'clock this morning yeah
coming off the injured list he had a
short shoulder he went on the injured
list on september 4th
fourth appearance first started and
immediately keegan in a jam an error and
a walk and now it's yelich no score
bottom of the first
back up the middle defender there is
nico horner to bodhi
and no play at first
so they get
the out in the middle and they'll be at
the corners first one to narvaez the
ball pulled on the ground at first
schwendale steps on the bag heading home
is long they've got the man in a rundown
yelich between first and second he is
tagged out and let's see did wang come
in to score no he did not
so it's a double play that ends the
inning schwendell
stepped on the bag to retire the
battered narvaez they got yelich in a
rundown we were waiting to see if wong
was going to head to the plate he never
did eric lauer an opportunity can handle
the bat a little bit hitting nearly 200
this year
up and in and he got hit they're going
to be loaded for colton wong long three
for nine with the bases loaded over the
course of this season
handles that chance and thompson gets
out eric lauer's been great so far six
up and six down
3-2 pitched ortega swinging a miss he
strikes out ortega and that is the third
strikeout of the afternoon for lauer the
emergence of the off-speed stuff
throwing that for strikes but again you
can't throw those unless you're throwing
your fastball for strikes and putting it
where you want it two ounce of man at
second it turns over to the top of the
order now in matt duffy
struck him out 94 mile an hour fastball
fourth strikeout for lauren here's
narvaez he hit into an inning ending
double play in the first and then
back to the mound sampson up with it
goes to second for one duffy back to
first two
fancy footwork matt duffy saving the day
there's that double
wisdom has put together a very solid
season leads the national league rookies
in home runs with 26.
got him looking got the call in the
inside corner and lauer records his
fifth strikeout
here we go
there's juan
third double play that the cub defense
has turned in the first four innings
here to start the top half of the fifth
inning and that'll bring up trace
thompson the right fielder
left field going back is
trace thompson
his first homer since 2018 he'll touch
him all the towering blasts
and it gives the cubs a one-nothing lead
nice to have you back in the big leagues
another outstanding swing
ball up and out over the plate got those
long arms extended first hit of the day
for the cubs and it's a long ball by
trace thompson so the brewers have had
all the base
runners is about the time the brewers
offense starts to come to life another
lead off base runner for the brewers and
here's the brewers lead off batter
colton wong
long right center gap bound down hits
off the top of the wall jbj is going to
be sent around third here's the throw
home no way tie game
just like that
how valuable has colton wong been my
goodness eduardo escobar trying to give
the brewers their first lead
to right that's down brewers are going
to have the lead
wong scores escobar cruises into second
base with an rbi double it's 2-1
milwaukee a mistake that escobar takes
advantage of
tying run now at third base for chicago
things got a little bit more stressful
now for hunter strickland david bodie
the batter
got him
three straight sliders david bode goes
down swinging another one out of the
strike zone down
cody trying to hit that one in lake
michigan comes up empty not done yet for
hunter strickland
patrick wisdom over two two strikeouts
tying run a third lead run at second for
the comes down got him swinging the
slider again lauer likes it now it's
austin romine eighth place hitter in
this lineup for chicago let's see if he
can come through and drive in the tying
run in this seventh inning got him three
straight nasty sliders from jake cousins
mom loves it adam morgan pitching holton
wong batting
out towards right center thompson out
there ortega
ortega makes the catch what a grab
never gave up on it
and hauled it in right up against the
fence that is
a big-time play
wilson contreras pinch hitting leading
off the cubs eighth inning
outside he walked him a 14 pitch played
appearance
and wilson contreras able to coax the
walk and the tying run is on so matt
duffy with a chance here for two of the
one
base hit down the line that one head
towards the left field corner contreras
race it for third and they're gonna send
it
and wilson could cherish him to score
matt duffy
rbi double and it is two
two
this one drilled out towards left center
yellidge will watch that bang up against
the wall jeffrey around third
duffy in the score frank squindell an
rbi double and frank the tank has given
the cubs a 3-2 lead so now two aborted
nobody out
and an opportunity for patrick wisdom
drilled the center going back bradley
turning looking out
patrick wisdom unloads
[Applause]
the cubs have opened up a 6-2 lead
and patrick wisdom
with his 27th and he now
has the cubs single season rookie record
for homers i'm sure somebody from the
ballpark will go retrieve that at some
point i would imagine that wisdom would
like to have that baseball yelling is in
there now brewers down to their final
strike ground ball left side base hit
that's going to bring home two runs wong
is in escobar is in you got a chip you
got a chance tying run coming up for the
brewers that's all you can ask for
that's all you hope for is to get that
tying one to the plate james peterson is
the batter for the crew
with the bases loaded
and two outs
settling under it and he's got it
and that's the ball game rucker closes
it out and the cubs win
adam all the way never a doubt